foreign  [Music]  [Music]  house  I'm the only one that made it out  [Music]  I got a job you did doing work cleaning  pools what are you doing bullets  cleaning them  and look if it get dark now you just you  just ride it okay yeah yeah  how do I do that  all right uh what's up  I work for the Army Corps of Engineers  now I need them to clear me so I can go  back you got blown up over there you  want to go back  I don't know what happened she was at a  car accident on the causeway  foreign  [Music]  medication like don't shoot yourself in  the head kind of medication okay  can you go back yes  should you go back it's a different  question  a pool business going  it's cutthroat  no  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]